.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
# U si stiige i Flüger,
flüge mit de Vögel furt,
# chöme nümme hei.
- Jetzt ist es verdammt kalt.
Auf und davon - viele wollen es,
nur wenige tun es.
Letztes Jahr haben wir Auswanderer
bei ihrem Abenteuer begleitet.
Wie geht es ihnen heute?
Wir haben sie erneut besucht.
* Jubel *
Marina Marrer und Mike Hostettler
eröffnen nach
heftigen Startschwierigkeiten ...
Meine Erste.
- ... in Florida einen Waffelshop.
Bald schon arbeiten sie
über 100 Std. in der Woche.
Mike erleidet einen Zusammenbruch.
Vor 14 Tagen
sagte mein Körper im Geschäft:
* Pfeifton *
"Stopp."
Schau mal, wie ich aussah.
- Du brauchtest Sonne.
Wie eine Leiche sah ich aus.
- Etwas bleich.
Jetzt ist Mike
wieder zurück im Geschäft.
Und er konnte sich
einen weiteren Traum erfüllen.
Da kannst du das Meer hören.
Bauernfamilie Wieser zieht
an die französische Atlantikküste.
Sie übernehmen
einen Hof mit 400 Tieren.
Von einem Tag auf den anderen
werden sie zu einem der grössten
Milchproduzenten der Region.
Ein Jahr später: Frankreich
leidet unter einer Jahrhundertdürre.
Auch der Hof unserer
Auswandererfamilie ist betroffen.
Es ist nicht lustig.
Wir Bauern
dürfen nicht mehr wässern.
Diesen Sommer in der Toskana
im Agriturismo von Eva Dudle
und Philippe Sguaitamatti.
Eva
gibt das Auswanderungsprojekt auf.
Ja, heute - so Gott will -
werde ich das Podere verkaufen.
Philippe und Eva
kennen sich zwei Jahre,
als sie
das Abenteuer Auswanderung wagen.
Ihr Projekt:
ein bäuerlicher Gästebetrieb
mit sechs Ferienwohnungen,
samt Swimmingpool und 18 ha Land.
Die beiden Pensionäre
werden zu Jungbauern.
Philippes erstes Projekt
ist ein Olivenhain.
# Si gö hüt no uf u drvo.
Ein Olivenhain mit 800 Bäumchen.
Philippe Sguaitamattis Vermächtnis
in der Toskana.
Nach einer schweren Krankheit
ist er knapp ein Jahr
nach seiner Auswanderung verstorben.
* Schwermütige Musik *
Es ist nun
sein Freund Alfonso Gianni,
der sich um die Bäumchen kümmert.
Molto attivo.
Molto appassionato a questo lavoro.
Der Olivenhain
war Philippes Herzensprojekt.
Dabei hatte es so schön begonnen.
Im Frühling 2021.
Philippe Sguaitamatti reist
mit einer grossen Vision im Herzen
in die Toskana.
Als Gutsverwalter des Agriturismo
muss er erste Vorbereitungen treffen.
Wir fuhren hier so viele Male durch,
als wir die Häuser suchten.
Das ist wie Heimkommen.
Die Liebe zu Italien
hat Philippe im Blut.
Seine Grosseltern stammen von hier.
Er kennt die Mentalität,
und sein Italienisch ist perfekt.
Freude und viele Erwartungen.
Erwartungen an ein Abenteuer.
Freude, dass ich mit meinen Händen
an etwas arbeiten kann.
Also ...
Das ist unser Zuhause.
Mit den Häusern.
Um als Agriturismo zu gelten,
müssen die Zürcher
Landwirtschaft betreiben.
Philippe
lässt 800 Olivenbäume anpflanzen.
Während in Italien
Philippe die Verantwortung trägt,
arbeitet Kapitalgeberin Eva
in der Schweiz weiter.
* Sanfte Flötenmusik *
Kinder haben Evas ganzes Leben
bestimmt.
So.
Es kann nicht jeder etwas machen.
Dann gibt es kein schloss.
Sie ist Kindergartenlehrerin
und selber Mutter von sieben Kindern.
Das muss ran. Das geht rundherum.
Sie nehmen alles von dort hinten.
Die Rentnerin ist froh,
weiterhin Geld zu verdienen.
Nicht mehr nehmen, ihr habt genug.
Geht da vorne arbeiten.
Nichts mehr nehmen.
Du auch nicht. Nichts mehr nehmen.
Wir sagten von Anfang an klar,
dass ich in der Schweiz bleibe.
Ich arbeite noch weiter.
Das wollte ich.
Er soll mal
die ganze Aufbauarbeit machen.
Das ganze Behördenzeugs ...
Ich kann ja
nicht so gut Italienisch,
dass ich das auch könnte.
Und ...
Ja ...
Zum Abschluss
macht ihr zu dritt ein Tor.
Und die Prinzessinnen
dürfen alle unten durchgehen
und sich anziehen.
* Entspannte Musik *
Damit die Olivenbäumchen
perfekt anwachsen können,
muss Jungbauer Philippe
die jungen Pflanzen bewässern.
Das ist etwas ganz Neues
und ich habe grosse Freude daran.
Giulio, der Sohn seines Freundes
Alfonso, hilft ihm dabei.
Das ist harte Arbeit.
Es sind im Ganzen 800 Bäume.
Es ist
nicht eine kleine Rosenplantage.
Da ist wirklich etwas dran.
* Entspannte Musik *
Während der Sommerferien
reiste auch Eva in die Toskana.
Die Zürcher sind auf Einkaufstour.
Warten.
Ist jemand drin?
- Hm?
- Ja.
Buongiorno.
- Buongiorno.
Vier.
Neue Vorhangstangen
für die Ferienwohnungen.
Gutsverwalter Philippe
bringt die Bescheinigung,
dass sie eine Firma besitzen.
So können sie gewisse Ausgaben
steuerlich absetzen.
Hast du alles?
- Jawohl. Ich hoffe es.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Sommer 2022
auf dem Hof der Bauernfamilie Wieser
im französischen Pays de la Loire.
Es ist heiss und trocken.
Die Natur leidet
unter einer historischen Dürre.
Wer kann, flüchtet in den Schatten.
Auch Bauernsohn Gian
hat ein Plätzchen gefunden.
Die Bäume und Sträucher
sind einem enormen Stress ausgesetzt.
Um zu überleben, werfen einzelne
schon jetzt die Blätter ab.
Eigentlich leben die Wiesers
in einer wasserreichen Gegend.
Doch jetzt sind Teile der Loire
praktisch ausgetrocknet.
Während Wochen durften die Bauern
nur nachts bewässern.
Jetzt ist auch damit Schluss:
Frankreich
hat den Notstand ausgerufen.
Es gilt
ein absolutes Bewässerungsverbot.
Jammern bringt nichts.
Wenn ich vor mich hin jammere,
es sei so trocken ...
Das weiss mittlerweile jeder.
Ich kann es ja nicht ändern.
Wir müssen
einfach den Bleistift spitzen.
Trotz Dürre und Hitze:
Die Bauern haben oft Besuch.
Seit ein paar Tagen
ist Sohn Sascha mit einem Freund da.
Au, das tut weh.
Sie vergrössern
den Schattenplatz für die Hühner.
Im Moment ist es nicht lustig.
Ganz ehrlich.
Der Mais ist nicht knusprig.
Wie es aussieht,
werden wir dazukaufen müssen.
Hätte es geregnet,
wären wir mit dem Mais flat gewesen.
Die Maiskolben wären gut gewesen.
Jetzt sind sie klein.
Eine Katastrophe wäre,
wenn wir gar nichts mehr hätten.
Wenn der ganze Mais kaputt wäre.
Das wäre etwas anderes.
Weil nun die Preise auf die Hektaren
so hoch sind.
Wenn man in Frankreich
jemandem Mais abkaufen will -
die Preise sind immens gestiegen.
Jenseits von Gut und Böse,
was die machen.
Aber das kommt schon gut.
Ich habe keine Bedenken.
So.
Es kommt den Wiesers zugute, dass sie
für ihre 400 Kühe nicht nur Mais,
sondern auch Gras angebaut haben.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Die Wasserleitung,
die Sandro für die nächtliche
Bewässerung extra angelegt hatte,
muss er wieder zusammenpacken.
Hier am Rand
ist es nicht so aussagekräftig.
Das fängt beim Kolben an.
Wenn wir so einen ansehen ...
Der ist sicher einen Drittel
so gross, wie er sein müsste.
Klar:
Ohne Wasser kann er nicht wachsen.
Er ist sehr schlecht ausgebildet.
Man sieht den Wassermangel klar.
Die Körnerreihen
sind nicht vollständig.
Normalerweise
müsste es gerade Reihen haben.
Der Mais sollte 1 m höher sein
und die Kolben doppelt so gross.
Die Ernte an eine Dürre verlieren,
das hätte sich Sandro
wohl kaum vorstellen können,
als er vor über einem Jahr
kurz vor dem Auswandern stand.
In der Schweiz
bewirtschafteten die Wiesers
einen kleinen Hof mit 50 Kühen.
Hauptberuflich war Sandro
in der Finanzbranche tätig.
Der Hof war sein Hobby.
Jetzt noch Kuh 2.
Es nervt mich nichts an der Schweiz.
Aber wie ich
Landwirtschaft betreiben will -
das ist in der Schweiz
nicht mehr gefragt.
Da bin ich zu stark Ökonom.
Ich kann das investierte Kapital
hier nicht so herauswirtschaften,
wie ich es gerne hätte.
Ausschliesslich Landwirtschaft
betreiben - und zwar gewinnbringend.
Ich habe vergessen,
Papi Tschüss zu sagen.
Dafür sind sie bereit, einen Teil
der Familie zurückzulassen.
Tschüss. Bis nächstes Jahr, Grosser.
Tschüss.
Alles gut. Sie kommen ja.
Haben wir alles? Masken ...
Hallo, das ist meine Joanna Bona,
mein Saschi Baschi ...
Die grossen zwei Kinder ...
... die fehlen schon.
Wenn man so etwas sieht ...
Da zweifelt man ein bisschen.
Aber wir haben
die Entscheidung getroffen.
Man muss mit den Konsequenzen leben.
Es ist nicht so, dass ich es bereue,
ausgewandert zu sein.
Im Gegenteil.
Hier haben wir eine Existenz
und können etwas aufbauen.
In der Schweiz war das ein Hobby.
Ihre neue Existenz:
der Hof Les Aubiers.
Im Frühjahr 2021 wechseln 359 Tiere,
der Futterbestand und
die landwirtschaftlichen Maschinen
ihren Besitzer.
Im hofeigenen Büro
wird überschrieben.
Ich würde sagen, dass ich 90 %
definitiv nicht verstanden habe.
10 % verstand ich.
Vielleicht "Apéro" und "Café".
Und das war es dann etwa.
In dieser Million Euro
noch nicht inbegriffen
sind die Gebäude,
das Wohnhaus und das Grundstück.
Einerseits verkauft man den Hof
und bricht die Zelte ab,
andererseits
stellt man die Zelte wieder auf
und kauft einen Hof.
Da hat man
schon manchmal Gewissensbisse
und fragt sich,
ob es der richtige Entscheid war.
Es ist eigentlich gut, dass wir
das immer wieder schauen können.
Es ging Schlag auf Schlag.
Diese Zeit ist bei mir
gar nicht präsent in der Erinnerung.
Die ist präsent auf Bildmaterial.
Unterschrieben
und notariell beglaubigt -
der riesige Hof
gehört nun den Schweizern.
Un, deux, trois.
Vor 29 Jahren wurden
Aleksandra und Sandro ein Paar.
Aggressionsprobleme.
Komm, Mutti, komm.
Alles war perfekt, sie heirateten.
Doch ihre Geschichte hat einen Bruch.
Das ist meine.
- Ja, es ist deine.
Wenn ich soft bin ...
- Ich bin nicht soft.
Nach sechs Ehejahren
liessen sie sich wieder scheiden.
Doch gerade mal zwei Jahre später
verliebten sie sich erneut
und heirateten zum zweiten Mal.
Hey, nein.
- Komm, mach.
Zwei Erwachsene, die zu dumm sind,
eine Matratze ...
Ich bin nicht zu dumm.
- Du hast einfach keine Kraft.
Siehst du? Ein Ruck.
Du musst sie noch zusammenschieben.
Nein, ich will etwas Distanz zu dir.
Künstlich.
Ich finde die Beziehung hier besser.
Meinst du das ernst?
- Ja.
Wie meinst du?
- Ich finde sie besser.
Was willst du? Was hast du gekauft?
- Nichts.
Sie ist harmonischer.
Wir haben ja sonst niemanden.
Da muss man fast.
Ah, es ist eine Zwangsehe.
* Sanftes Pfeifen *
Komm, gehen.
Kommt, ihr müsst gehen. Gehen.
Das gilt für alle.
Gut 6'500 l Milch
gibt seine Holstein-Herde täglich.
Der Vorbesitzer des Hofs,
Patrice Rondeau,
ist nun einer
von Wiesers drei Angestellten.
30 Jahre war er Besitzer, jetzt
muss er Sandros Neuerungen mittragen.
Statt um 6.30 Uhr
wird neu um 5.30 Uhr gemolken.
Der Übergang lief so weit gut.
Ich versuche immer daran zu denken,
wie es ist,
wenn Gian dann mal im Boot sitzt
und Ideen hat.
Wie ich dann reagieren würde.
Vielleicht
wäre ich auch eher kritisch,
aber es käme dann doch gut.
Ich darf leicht arrogant angehaucht
behaupten,
dass ich den Laden im Griff habe.
Ich weiss was, wie, wo, wann.
Ja.
Mhm.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Tampa in Florida.
Unsere Auswanderer Marina und Mike
haben eine neue Leidenschaft:
Stand-up-Paddling.
Und sie haben sogar Zeit dafür.
Bye.
Was in den letzten zwei Jahren ...
Wenn man nur arbeitet, funktioniert
der Körper manchmal nicht mehr.
Momentan ist das Leben sicher
schöner als noch vor zwei Jahren,
als wir starteten
und alles etwas schieflief.
Jetzt ist es umso schöner.
Lange hat das Glück
einen grossen Bogen um sie gemacht.
Und Zeit, dieses wertvolle Gut, war
den beiden komplett abhandengekommen.
Zuverlässige Angestellte
halten ihnen nun den Rücken frei.
Der Crystal River, knapp 1 Std.
von ihrem Zuhause entfernt,
ist das Reich der Manatees,
der Seekühe.
Harmlose Riesenviecher.
Du Idiot.
Dass die beiden ihr Leben in Florida
endlich auch geniessen können,
dafür brauchten sie
wahrhaftig Stehvermögen.
Aufhören
wäre zweifellos einfacher gewesen.
Hier fing alles an:
Reichenbach im Kandertal
war ihr Zuhause.
Hier führte Mike
nebenberuflich ein Tattoo-Studio.
Das war einmal. Tschüss und weg.
Seine grosse Leidenschaft.
Amerika ist seit bald 20 Jahren ...
... ein Traum.
Ich war schon früher
ein Indianer/Cowboy-Freak.
Die Route 66 machte mir immer Lust.
Endlich kann der Traum wahr werden.
Ihr Ticket für Amerika sind Waffeln.
Als Franchisenehmer wollen sie
in Tampa einen Waffelshop eröffnen.
Der Traum Amerika
kommt mehr vom Mike.
Aber für mich
war einfach immer schon klar ...
... dass ich nicht ewig
am gleichen Ort bleiben will.
Ich möchte Neues erleben.
Ich möchte neue Leute kennenlernen.
Möglichst viel erleben.
Die Schweiz ist zu klein.
Die ist nichts auf der ganzen Welt.
Kalt, Schnee - wäh.
Bestens vorbereitet verlassen
die beiden ehemaligen Polizisten
kurz vor der Coronapandemie
die Schweiz.
* Melancholische Musik *
Mike, mach es gut.
Merci für alles. Man sieht sich.
Tschüss.
* Fröhliche Musik *
* Erwartungsvolle Musik *
Im Norden Tampas,
in einer ruhigen Wohngegend,
hissen sie die Berner Flagge.
Doch kaum haben sie amerikanischen
Boden unter den Füssen,
bricht die Pandemie aus.
Die Welt ist plötzlich eine andere.
Ihr Traum kommt gehörig ins Trudeln.
Mit dem Netz bringst du alles raus.
Dann bin sogar ich zufrieden.
Wenn kein Stäubchen oder Dreck
mehr drin ist.
Ich bin etwas heikel.
Scheisse.
Schau dir das an.
Da hast du dein super Netz gekauft.
Der Umbau ihres Waffelrestaurants
kommt kaum vom Fleck.
Gleichwohl laufen die Kosten weiter:
Inventar, Versicherungen,
Haus- und Lokalmiete.
Auch die Visumsverlängerungen
sind eine Zitterpartie.
Denn die Einwanderungsbehörde
arbeitet nur reduziert.
Da kommen schon Zweifel auf.
Geht es weiter? Wie geht es weiter?
Wir sind mitten im Umbau.
Wir haben sehr viel Geld investiert.
Und auch Nerven.
Unsere Existenz hängt daran.
- Ja.
Wir redeten oft darüber,
wie unsere Situation aussieht ...
... und auch
über die Schritte und die Zeit,
die wir ausgewählt haben.
Ja.
Das will ich nicht noch mal.
- Es war mühsam.
Ursprünglich glaubten die beiden,
dass sie ihr Lokal zwei Monate
nach Ankunft eröffnen können.
Doch nach fünf Monaten
ist der Waffelshop
im Grand Plaza Shoppingcenter
noch immer eine Baustelle.
Seit Wochen
verlieren sie täglich Geld.
Der Umbau im Laden
sind rund 70'000 ¤.
Mhm.
Das reichte dann nicht.
Die ganze Möblierung
und die Dekosachen ...
Alles in allem kostet es uns -
über den Daumen gepeilt ...
... ca. 200'000 ¤.
So dort herum.
Vieles macht einen auch stärker.
Man lernt ...
... durch die äusseren Einflüsse,
die wir nicht steuern konnten,
ganz anders
mit gewissen Situationen umzugehen.
Gerade, was das Finanzielle angeht.
Ursprünglich hatten wir geplant,
dass wir gewisse Geräte im Laden
leasen.
Das machten sie
aber wegen Corona nicht.
Wir bezahlten alles bar.
Im Nachhinein
sind wir mehr als happy,
dass das ganze Inventar
und alles, was im Laden ist,
uns gehört,
wir also niemandem was schulden.
Das sehe ich mittlerweile als Plus.
Das sehe ich positiv.
* Entspannte Musik *
Zurück in die Toskana.
Schon kurz nach der Auswanderung
trennen sich die Zürcher wieder.
Deswegen das Agriturismo
aufgeben kommt nicht infrage.
Sie werden zu Geschäftspartnern.
Ihr Gästebetrieb
ist noch nicht offiziell eröffnet,
als sich unverhofft
schon erste Besucherinnen anmelden.
Eva ist überrumpelt.
Schliesslich fehlen in der Küche
noch Töpfe und Geschirr.
Es hat
noch einen unrealistischen ...
... Touch, weil es irgendwie ...
Es gibt noch so viel zu tun,
bis sie kommen.
Keine Ahnung, ob ich das schaffe.
Nur in dieser Wohnung
ist die Küche schon eingebaut.
Wo willst du den?
Den muss man noch waschen.
Gutsverwalter Philippe
ist in seinem Element.
Einmal Zwetschge.
Hier in Italien
kann er auch Gastgeber sein.
Geld war Eva nie wichtig.
Gastfreundschaft
steht bei ihr an oberster Stelle.
Die Seele
muss sich zu Hause fühlen können.
Das ist für mich hier
einfach sehr wichtig.
Ich will kein Kommerzunternehmen.
Ich will etwas machen,
wo Leute zur Ruhe kommen können.
Ich finde, man sollte
in so ein Haus kommen und finden:
"Boah, da fühle ich mich wohl."
* Träge Musik *
Auch der Sommer 2021 ist trocken.
Wochenlang regnet es nicht.
Würden die jungen Bäumchen
nicht bewässert -
sie würden die heissen Monate
kaum überleben.
Noch dürfen die Zürcher den Wasser-
speicher einer Nachbarin anzapfen.
Trotz der Nachbarschaftshilfe -
den Zürchern ist sehr wohl bewusst,
dass sie dringend einen
eigenen Grundwasserbrunnen brauchen.
Denn ihre Quelle ist versiegt.
Sie müssen 10'000 Euro zusätzlich
in die Hand nehmen.
Sie lassen sich
von ihrem Treuhänder beraten.
Dazu kommt: Um den Status Agriturismo
nicht zu verlieren,
müssen sie weiter
in die Landwirtschaft investieren.
Sonst drohen happige Nachsteuern.
Noch mehr Land urbar machen,
hiesse Leute anstellen.
Das kostet.
Einen Kredit aufnehmen, empfehlen
der Treuhänder und Philippe.
Doch das
kommt für Eva nicht infrage.
Ich bin 67. Ich will das
wieder zurückzahlen können.
Ich will keine Schulden haben.
Ich muss nachher
hier mit meiner AHV leben.
Mit Schulden
geht das schon mal nicht.
Trotz des Alters
noch einmal durchstarten.
Die Zürcher haben die Aufgabe
sicherlich unterschätzt.
Dank ihrer Lebenserfahrung weiss Eva
aber auch, wann sie aufhören muss.
Sie verabschiedet sich von Philippe
und entscheidet sich,
das Agriturismo aufzugeben.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Auch Gutsverwalter Philippe
muss Abschied nehmen.
Es ist überwältigend schön.
Ich habe mich wahnsinnig
an die Olivenbäume,
an die Gegend und die Leute hier
gebunden.
Ich dachte, wir wären zu zweit
und hätten eine gute Idee.
Wir hätten
einen guten Draht zum Land usw.
Aber ja, wenn es nicht klappt,
klappt es halt nicht.
* Melancholische Musik *
Ach ja.
Wenig später erkrankt Philippe schwer
und reist in die Schweiz zurück.
Philippe
stirbt im Kreise seiner Familie.
Im Sommer 2022:
Eva ist noch einmal
in die Toskana zurückgekehrt.
Es tut mir sehr leid,
dass er seinen Traum
nur so kurz leben konnte.
Dass er all die Freundschaften hier
verlassen musste.
Ich habe erlebt, wie ein junger Mann
in einer Eisenwarenhandlung
in Tränen ausbrach,
als ich sagte,
Philippe käme nicht mehr zurück,
weil er so krank sei.
Die Leute trugen das sehr mit.
Und sie litten wirklich auch mit.
Das war ihm gar nicht so bewusst.
Ich kriegte das mit,
als ich im Dezember hier war.
Man merkte, wie verwurzelt er war.
Er hatte seine Leute hier
und wusste, was ihm gefällt.
Ja.
Emotional
hat sich Eva schon vor geraumer Zeit
von ihrem gemeinsamen
Projekt Auswandern verabschiedet.
Nun will sie
das Agriturismo verkaufen.
Ich räume jetzt auf und gehe wieder.
Er hatte seine Sachen auch
schon geholt, als er noch konnte.
Und ...
Daher ...
Ich habe meine Familie hier,
das ist gut.
Sie helfen mir, wieder einzupacken.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Zum letzten Mal Ferien im Agriturismo
der Nonna in der Toskana.
Auch eine Freundin
ist extra angereist.
Eva ist froh,
ihre Liebsten bei sich zu haben.
Dann müssen wir hier einen Knopf
machen und abschneiden.
Okay. Die Schere musst du mitnehmen.
Das Agriturismo soll in diesen Tagen
den Besitzer wechseln.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Auf dem Hof Les Aubiers
hat Bauersohn Gian Glück.
Den Swimmingpool hatten die Wiesers
schon vor Wochen gefüllt.
Im Büro kauft Sandro
einem Nachbarn 300 t Mais ab.
11'000 Euro -
ein unerwarteter Budgetposten.
* Lockere Musik *
2021 freuen sich die Wiesers
über eine ausgezeichnete Ernte.
Es schneit.
Die Arbeit macht dem ehemaligen
Hobbybauern riesig Spass.
Ja.
Ja, es darf so weitergehen.
Träumen darf man ja.
Für die Realität
ist man selber verantwortlich.
Für den Schweizer ist es wichtig,
seinen Tieren
genügend Gras verfüttern zu können,
denn Gras
ist proteinhaltiger als Mais.
Die Bauern
gönnen sich kaum eine Pause
und oft wird es fast Mitternacht,
bis die Maschinen stillstehen.
Ja, 54 ha.
Das ist genau dreimal
der Betrieb in der Schweiz.
Verrückt, oder?
- Mhm.
Ja, dreimal.
Schön ist, wie sie mitmachen.
Sie sind es
eigentlich nicht gewohnt,
in diesen Dimensionen
Gras zu silieren.
Gras
ist für sie ein notwendiges Übel.
Sie sind auf Mais festgefahren.
Mais gibt halt weniger Arbeit.
In der Schweiz
silierte Sandro 300 t Gras.
Hier sind es fünfmal so viel -
nebst 4'000 t Mais.
Ja, komm.
Ich werde oft gefragt,
ob ich in den Sommerferien war.
Dann zucke ich mit den Schultern
und sage:
"Nein, ich habe mich dafür
entschieden, Bauer zu sein."
"Und das bin ich 365 Tage."
Im Moment
erlaubt es das einfach nicht,
dass ich zwei Wochen Öpalöma
irgendwo an einem Strand liege.
Öpalöma, gibt es das?
- Es geht einfach nicht.
Es läuft so viel ...
Die Zeit wird kommen,
wo wir uns das erlauben können.
Aber sicherlich nicht ...
Wenn man
einen Laden rauffahren will ...
Fragt mal Bill Gates, ob er in den
ersten fünf Jahren Ferien machte.
Es ist ein blöder Vergleich,
aber das geht doch nicht.
Bis ich 50 bin -
das geht ja nicht mehr so lange ...
... ist der Pinsel einfach unten.
Gib ihm.
Es braucht schon zwei, die Ja sagen.
Definitiv.
Ich weiss, dass Sandro
nicht vom Regen in die Traufe geht.
Das weiss ich.
Da ist er schon der Fels.
* Erwartungsvolle Musik *
Um den Nachwuchs auf Les Aubiers
kümmert sich die Bäuerin.
Kuckuck, schaut mal, wer da ist.
So hat es Aleksandra
in der Schweiz gelernt.
Fast jeden zweiten Tag
kommt ein Junges zur Welt.
6 l Milch kriegt jedes Kalb.
Das braucht extrem viel Kraft.
Aber nicht mehr lange.
Ich habe ein Taxi-Lait gekauft.
Damit kann man rumfräsen.
Megacool.
Ja.
So zu arbeiten ist ziemlich uncool.
Noch schleppt sie
die schweren Kannen selber.
Das Taxi-Lait hat sie erst bestellt.
Mit diesem elektrischen Milchwagen
wird die Fütterung der Kälber
einfacher werden.
Das ist die Kultur.
- Ja, das ist die Kultur.
Die Landwirtschaftsbetriebe
in Frankreich sind wirklich ...
Ich kenne so viele Bauern,
die schöne Betriebe haben,
aber die Frau
geht auswärts arbeiten.
Es ist hier nicht normal,
dass eine Frau auf dem Betrieb ist
oder eine Maschine fährt.
Nein, das ist eine ganz andere Welt.
Eine Neuanschaffung haben sie
bereits in Betrieb genommen:
den automatischen Futteranschieber.
Das ist der günstigste Mitarbeiter,
den ich habe.
Durch den Roboter
spart er nicht nur Zeit,
seine Tiere
bekommen auch mehr Futter.
Und somit steigt der Milchertrag.
Die Ideen
gehen dem Schweizer Bauern nicht aus.
Das hatte er
schon als junger Mensch.
Du wolltest schon damals mehr.
Und wenn du das erreicht hattest,
hast du was Neues angezogen.
Und dann wieder was Neues.
- Ja ...- Es ist so.
Ja ...
In der Landwirtschaft
kann man nicht sagen,
man finde etwas,
das man sich erträumt hat.
Das ist etwas,
das man in Generationen,
Jahreszeiten, in Jahren denken muss.
Man hat nicht ein Projekt
für ein, zwei Jahre
und melkt mal ein paar Kühe.
Darum geht es nicht.
Das sind permanente Prozesse.
Es ist schwierig,
eine Prognose zu machen.
Ja, in zehn Jahren ...
- Da bin ich in Kanada.
Was machst du dort?
- Eine Farm kaufen.
In Kanada?
- Ja.
Ich dachte, du wolltest hier
bleiben.- Zu klein.
Zu klein?
- Ja, er ist sein Vater.
* Entspannte Musik *
Um Monate verspätet -
endlich nimmt Mikes und Marinas
American Dream wieder Fahrt auf.
Sie feiern
die Eröffnung ihres Waffelladens.
Ich zittere schon.
Ich bin verdammt nervös.
Mike war einst Schreiner,
dann jahrelang Polizist
und nebenbei Tätowierer.
Ich habe noch nie
so ein Business betrieben.
Servieren usw. ist für mich fremd.
Daher bin ich schon etwas ...
... nervös.
Kurz vor Eröffnung
noch schnell die Saucen aufrühren.
Scheisse! Au.
Mit dem Bohrer.
Ah, Scheisse. Kannst du mir helfen?
- Sicher.
Aber Achtung, schau.
Das war nicht ich.
Der Boden ist sowieso dreckig.
- Scheisse.
* Spassige Musik *
Du hast nicht jeden Tag
eine Bohrmaschine in den Fingern.
"Mit mehr Drücken
geht es schneller."
Trotzdem: Punktgenau um 17 Uhr ...
* Erwartungsvolle Musik *
Es sieht so leer aus.
Musstest du weinen?
- Die ersten Kunden, und ich weine.
Warum?
Weil ich erleichtert war
und mich freute,
dass ich recht hatte und es gut kam.
Es sieht schon geil aus.
Und zum ersten Mal serviert Mike
eine Waffel
als eigenständiger Unternehmer.
Meine Erste.
* Zufriedene Musik *
Hi.
Es fiel einfach
ein riesiger Stein vom Herzen.
Es war immer noch herausfordernd,
man muss das Business
ja erst mal noch zum Laufen bringen.
Aber dass man endlich eröffnen
und das starten konnte,
was wir wollten ...
Für mich war das megaschön.
Die Waffeln finden Anklang.
Marina und Mike
arbeiten bald 14 Std. täglich,
sieben Tage in der Woche.
You can have the waffles
with Hersheys, Reese's, Oreos,
Twix, Snickers, KitKat, gummy bears,
M&Ms, Kinder Bueno, Kinder Riegel,
Raffaello or Ferrero Rocher.
Pumpkin spiced latte.
Im Moment ist einfach arbeiten,
arbeiten, arbeiten angesagt.
Und noch mal arbeiten.
Aber das wird irgendwann anders.
Corona
hat uns so viel Geld gekostet.
Mehr Geld,
das wir nicht so eingeplant hatten.
Wir hatten
nach wie vor Existenzängste.
Den grossen Durchbruch
hatten wir im Januar.
Im Januar 2021.
Das war brutal.
Dort waren wir ...
Die letzten zwei Monate
waren etwas schleppend und mühsam.
Zeitweise
war man stundenlang im Laden
und hatte keine Kunden.
Und von einem Tag auf den anderen
wurden wir überrannt
und generierten einen Umsatz ...
Wir sagten immer:
"Wenn wir das erreicht haben,
ist es wunderschön."
Drei Monate nach Eröffnung hatten
wir das und es ging nicht mehr weg.
Doch der grosse Erfolg
hat seinen Preis.
Mike erleidet einen Zusammenbruch.
Wie aus dem nichts
hat er eines Tages Panikattacken,
kann nicht mehr.
Ein Burn-out.
Der Arzt verordnet ihm
sofortige Ruhe und Medikamente.
Vor 14 Tagen
sagte mein Körper im Geschäft:
* Pfeifton *
"Stopp, zu viel des Guten."
Der Blutdruck stieg massiv an
und kam nicht mehr runter.
Ich dachte zuerst,
ich hätte einen Schlaganfall.
Meine rechte Seite
war taub und komisch.
Ich setzte mich erst mal hin
und versuchte wirklich alles.
Aber irgendwann ging es nicht mehr.
Im Waffelshop trägt Marina
die Verantwortung allein.
Ihr Partner fehlt überall.
* Schwermütige Musik *
Can I call you back later?
Sorry, I'm pretty busy.
Or can you send me an email?
Eine Zeit voller Unsicherheit:
Lange ist unklar, wann Mike
ins Geschäft zurückkehren wird.
Es war schon belastend.
Oder immer noch. Es war halt so ...
Ja ... Ich fühlte mich
auf jeden Fall allein.
Ich hatte zum Glück die Energie.
Es hätte auch sein können,
dass ich das nicht kann.
Es war eine grosse Herausforderung.
Und wieder
einmal mehr das Thema Corona.
Niemand aus der Schweiz
konnte kommen.
Meine Eltern konnten nicht kommen,
mein Bruder konnte nicht kommen,
um mich zu unterstützen.
Theoretisch haben wir Leute,
die uns helfen würden.
Die würden
um die ganze Welt reisen für uns.
Sie durften einfach nicht einreisen.
Daran zerbrach ich fast.
Ich versuche jetzt halt auch wieder,
das Positive daraus zu ziehen:
Nicht mal das brachte
unsere Beziehung zum Scheitern.
Es brachte uns enger zusammen.
Es brachte mich
enger mit meinen Eltern zusammen.
Ich hatte
viele gute Gespräche mit ihnen.
Ja.
Es war eine harte Zeit.
Einmal mehr.
Darum sind wir erst recht stolz
darauf, dass wir es geschafft haben.
Daumen hoch.
- (Mit Akzent) Thumbs up.
Das sagt mein Bruder immer.
- Genau.
* Zufriedene Musik *
In diesem heissen Sommer
an der französischen Atlantikküste.
Ferien kennen die Bauernleute nicht.
Doch beim Schlemmen
im Maison d'Eclusier
kommt zumindest das Gefühl auf.
Es ist heiss. Es ist wirklich heiss.
Morgen kommt die Spitze mit 39 °C.
- 39 °C?
Non, c'est moi.
Schon morgen
reist Sascha wieder nach Hause.
Der 22-Jährige
ist oft zu Besuch bei den Eltern -
bereits das fünfte Mal.
Es ist kein Katzensprung mehr
wie vorher,
als man in 20 Min. mit dem Motorrad
oder Auto in Oberhof war.
Aber mit dem Flugzeug
dauert es 2 1/2 Std.
Wie viel?
- Zweieinhalb.- Anderthalb.
Ja, mit Check-in,
nach Basel fahren ...
Ja ...
- Von Nantes zu euch ...
Das ist eigentlich okay.
Fast wie von Oberhof nach Zürich.
- In etwa, ja.
* Träge Musik *
Tschüss, Mutti.
- Hey, tschüss.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
- Schön, dass ihr hier wart.
Au revoir, maman.
Vorsichtig fahren.
* Entspannte Musik *
(Gian) Weinst du?
- Ja.
Der kleine Gian lernt früh,
dass Abschiednehmen zum Leben gehört.
* Zufriedene Musik *
Sommer 2022:
Mike ist schon früh auf den Beinen -
nicht wegen der Arbeit.
Seit acht Wochen stehe ich
jeden Morgen um 6.20 Uhr auf.
Meine Tochter Alina ist hier.
Sie geht hier zur Schule.
Sie macht ein 10. Schuljahr.
Um Englisch zu lernen.
Und der Unterricht
beginnt um 7.30 Uhr.
Darum habe ich das Vergnügen.
Alina ist eine Tochter
aus einer früheren Beziehung.
(Singend) Alina.
Löschst du
dann bitte überall das Licht?
Ja.
- Wo ist die schwarze Jacke?
Im Schrank.
- Okay.
Nicht vergessen.- Ich weiss nicht,
ob ich die farbige mitnehmen soll.
* Entspannte Musik *
Bist du bereit?
Die Fahrt ist kurz: 10 Min. bloss.
Fast jeden Tag.- Fast jeden Tag
fahren wir so zur Schule.
Das hat sich eingeschlichen,
dass ich dich morgens bringe.
Das ist auch für mich,
damit wir Zeit füreinander haben.
Am Nachmittag arbeitest du ja.
- Meistens.
Meistens.
Dann nimmst du den Schulbus.
Als sich erhärtete,
dass Alina wirklich
zu uns nach Florida kommt ...
Klar, das erfüllt mich mit Stolz
und ich freue mich extrem.
Sie ist meine Tochter.
Dass sie den Wunsch
von sich aus geäussert hat ...
Ja, seit sie hier ist,
ist es ein komplett anderes Leben.
Und das ist gut. Es macht Spass.
Also, tschüss.
- Tschüss.
Tschüss.
Alles ist viel chilliger.
Die Amerikaner sind easier drauf.
Man kann im Unterricht
schlafen, essen, am Handy sein ...
Das interessiert niemanden. Genau.
Die Tarpon Spring High School.
1'800 Schüler besuchen sie.
Die 15-jährige Schweizerin
ist nun eine von ihnen.
* Entspannte Musik *
Innerlich
hatte Eva ihr Auswanderungsabenteuer
schon lange losgelassen.
Heute
soll es offiziell sein Ende nehmen.
Ja, heute - so Gott will -
werde ich das Podere verkaufen.
Nicht mal einen Monat war das Podere,
das Agriturismo,
zum Verkauf ausgeschrieben,
und Evas Maklerin hatte einen
valablen Interessenten gefunden.
Den Verkauf wickelten
die Maklerin und der Treuhänder ab.
Eva will nur unterschreiben müssen.
Die Möbel bleiben hier.
Ausgesuchte Bilder
sind im Preis nicht inbegriffen.
Kann man dir helfen?
- Ja, gerne.
Könntest du mir
bitte die Bilder abhängen
und ich verpacke sie?
- Ja.
Man muss noch Plastik schneiden.
- Ein Pferd, hm?
Von Natur aus tatkräftig
und nach vorne schauend,
liebäugelt Eva bereits
mit einem kleinen Gut in Frankreich.
Ich denke, wenn die Abmachungen
vom Käufer eingehalten werden ...
... die Alberto Bay-macario aus
Mailand für mich ausgehandelt hat,
geht es mir gut.
Dann musste ich ein bisschen
dranbezahlen und der Rest ...
... lief wirklich gut.
Schon einmal wurde die
Vertragsunterzeichnung verschoben.
Heute soll sie gelingen.
* Entspannte Musik *
Im Haus der Florida-Auswanderer
sind nun alle Bewohner wach.
Marina ist ein Familienmensch.
Ihr gefällt es,
dass Alina eingezogen ist.
Wir unternehmen wieder mehr.
Also, Mike und ich mit Alina.
Weil wir einfach ihr
auch Dinge zeigen wollen.
Man vergisst das nicht,
aber man unternimmt sonst weniger.
Man ist so im Alltagstrott.
Und ...
Man vergisst manchmal,
was man alles machen könnte.
Mit ihr unternehmen wir wieder mehr.
Das finde ich schön.
Die Unternehmer beschäftigen
zurzeit sieben Teilzeitangestellte.
Die entlasten.
Vor acht Monaten
hat Mike sein Tattoo-Studio
hier in Amerika eröffnet.
Weniger im Waffelshop stehen, dafür
seine Passion leben: das Tätowieren.
Das half Mike
in seine alte Form zurückzufinden.
Die Erfahrung der Krankheit
aber bleibt ein Teil von ihm.
Ich habe mich mittlerweile
sehr gut erholt.
Körperlich
geht es mir wieder sehr gut.
Und ...
Ja ...
Ich bin wieder da.
Oder, Scha?
Ja, ich lerne immer noch ...
... gewisse Dinge
entspannter zu sehen.
Und nicht so ernst und ...
... persönlich.
Halt eher
an das Positive zu denken ...
... und nicht zuerst ans Negative.
Scha,
deine Lieblingskatze will rein.
Mhm.
* Miauen *
Die Hündin ...
- Djuni.
... ist mit ihnen ausgewandert.
- Hopp.
Die Katze hat Marina aufgelesen
und aufgepäppelt.
Baghira ist ein vollwertiges
Familienmitglied geworden.
Djuna ist ja nicht mein Tier.
Die hat Mike
mit nach Hause gebracht. Gell?
Mhm.
- Und ...
Ich mag Haustiere.
Das war schon immer so.
Das war sicher auch ein Punkt,
der manchmal stressig war,
aber doch tat uns das gut.
Meine Mutter sagte mal,
als sie hier war,
Djuna
würde uns halt doch viel geben.
Das gibt einem auch Halt.
Ja ...
Du gingst jeweils
lange mit ihr spazieren.- Mhm.
Im Agriturismo warten Eva,
die Maklerin und der Treuhänder
auf die Käufer.
Dass die Vertragsunterzeichnung schon
einmal kurzfristig verschoben wurde,
macht sie nervös.
Um 11 Uhr ...
- ... haben wir uns verabredet.
Wir haben uns um 11 Uhr verabredet.
Er ist Deutscher,
er sollte eigentlich pünktlich sein.
Vor 11 Uhr.
Seit einer halben Stunde
sollten die Käufer hier sein.
Warten wir noch ein wenig.
Abwarten, hoffen und beten.
* Hupen *
- Er kommt.- Oh.
* Bellen *
Er ist hier.
Mamma mia, che sorpresa.
- Freude.
Drei Hamburger wollen die neuen
Besitzer des Agriturismo werden.
Hallo, ich bin Thorsten.
- Ich bin Eva.
Im Frühjahr waren die Deutschen
zum ersten Mal hier.
Das Agriturismo
hatte ihnen auf Anhieb zugesagt.
Hier ist der spitze Bleistift drin.
Endlich hier.
Doch
noch einmal gehen sie auf eine Runde.
Es geht um viel Geld.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Wenn du dir die Küche vorstellst,
passt das.- Ja.
Ist ein Tourist
ein, zwei Wochen hier,
findet er die Fliesen schön.
Die sind auch schön.
- Ja.
Ich finde schön, dass jede Wohnung
eine überdachte Terrasse hat.
Gut, wollt ihr
die anderen auch noch sehen?
Ne, alles gut.
Doch, wenn wir schon mal dabei sind.
Komm, die 3 Min.
Die ruhige Lage des Anwesens
und seine Nähe zum Meer,
das hat die Deutschen überzeugt.
Schauen wir, ob sie wirklich
die Unterschrift daruntersetzten.
* Zufriedene Musik *
Lange haben sie in Frankreich
auf den Regen gewartet.
Für 2'000 t Mais kam er zu spät.
Der Ernteertrag ist jetzt
in den Flachsilos eingelagert:
1'000 t Gras und 850 t Mais.
Wir haben hier und hier ...
... die beiden Maissilos ...
Im Normalfall
ist der Maissilo 1 m höher.
Und v.a. bis vorne voll.
Jetzt ist er 1 m tiefer.
Mit dieser Trockenheit
und dem Bewässerungsverbot ...
... kamen wir volumenmässig
mit einem blauen Auge davon.
Wir haben
einfach keine Reserve mehr.
Wie die Qualität ist,
wird sich zeigen,
wenn wir es in vier oder fünf Wochen
aufmachen.
Die Hälfte der Maisernte
haben die Wiesers verloren.
Mit einem Zukauf konnten sie
einen Teil davon wieder wettmachen.
Trotz schlechter Ernte:
Die Schweizer glauben
an eine Zukunft in Frankreich.
Die 25-jährige Melkmaschine
soll durch eine Roboteranlage
ersetzt werden.
Dann entscheiden die Kühe,
wann sie gemolken werden wollen.
So können Arbeitskräfte
eingespart werden.
Auf Les Aubiers wird bald die
grösste Anlage der Region stehen.
Es hilft, dass wir im ersten Jahr
supergut arbeiten konnten.
Und ja, das Investitionsvolumen,
das besteht ...
... sind die Hypotheken,
die wir jetzt erhöht haben.
Klar.
Das kann man
nicht aus der Portokasse zahlen.
Es hilft,
was zurzeit am Markt läuft.
Milch ist gesucht wie noch nie.
Super Milchpreise ...
Was übrig bleibt,
investieren wir sofort wieder.
Ich will eine saubere Installation.
Das ist die letzte,
die ich in meinem Leben mache.
Die muss halten.
Wegen des Melkens früh aufstehen,
gibt es dann nicht mehr.
* Neugierige Musik *
Nein. Lass ihn bitte stehen.
Das ist wirklich streng.
Gian lernt die Landwirtschaft
von der Pike auf.
Oder hast du absichtlich umgestellt?
Gian soll auch mit der Aufzucht
der Kälber vertraut werden.
Danke.
Aleksandra geniesst die Zeit
mit dem jüngsten Sohn.
Gut. Das sind 4 l,
du hast aber drei Kälber.
Ja, und?
- Da fehlt was.- 2 l.
Ja, also. Jetzt drückst du da drauf.
Noch mal.
Schon gut.
Finger weg, sonst kommt noch mal.
Den ganzen Sommer,
zwei oder drei Monate lang ...
Ich weiss es nicht mehr.
Seit März war das Haus immer voll.
Wir hatten immer Besuch.
Meistens waren alle Zimmer besetzt.
So war das Heimweh nicht da,
weil alle hier waren.
Jetzt ist mal Ruhe.
Ehrlich gesagt bin froh,
wenn kein Besuch da ist.
Über die Kleinen nähert sich Gian
langsam den Grossen an.
Vor den ausgewachsenen
700 kg schweren Kühen
hat der Zehnjährige
noch gehörigen Respekt.
Jetzt
geht es gemütlich zum Abendessen.
Jetzt kannst du
das Taxi-Lait waschen.
Tochter Alina ist in der Schule,
Papa Mike und Marina
öffnen Punkt 11 Uhr den Waffelshop.
Die Angestellten übernehmen das
Geschäft im Laufe des Nachmittags.
Ich habe die Scheissfolie
gestern gewechselt ...
Ich habe es ihr gesagt,
aber sie lachte nur.
Gestern die Folie gewechselt,
heute sieht es aus wie Sau.
Das gibt es doch nicht.
Sie könnten es jeweils kurz putzen.
- Ja, v.a. ...
Das war gestern sauber.
Und man lässt es einfach.
Man könnte es kurz putzen.
- Man kann es ja noch umkehren.
Das ist mir ein Rätsel.
Das werde ich nie verstehen.
Wir haben
sehr viele Junge angestellt.
Die sehen es anders oder nicht -
anders als ältere Leute.
Und ... Ja.
Aber wir
können uns glücklich schätzen.
Wir hatten jetzt einen Abend frei.
Wir können die Mitarbeiter
arbeiten lassen.
Wir haben
keine schlechten Bewertungen.
Wir kriegen super Kundenfeedback.
Alle seien megafreundlich.
Ich halte mich daran fest.
Das regt mich manchmal auch auf,
aber das stärkt mich.
Wir sind in Amerika und
der amerikanische Kunde freut sich.
Warum soll ich mich aufregen?
Gelassenheit:
Mike kann noch einiges
von Marina lernen.
Wir sind sehr zufrieden damit,
wie es läuft.
Der Sommer ist unsere Hochsaison.
Da läuft extrem viel.
Jetzt kommen die ruhigeren Monate.
September, Oktober, November
sind immer etwas ruhiger.
Und ab Dezember/Januar
wird es wieder mehr sein.
Im Grossen und Ganzen
sind wir sehr zufrieden.
Wir sind froh,
noch Mike's Fine Art zu haben.
Also, das Tätowieren.
So kann man die schlechteren Monate
etwas ausbalancieren.
Im Sommer hatte er weniger Aufträge,
dafür hatten wir hier mehr Arbeit.
Ja.
Marina und Mikes amerikanisches
Geschäftsmodell funktioniert.
Ben Browning war Mikes
erster amerikanischer Tattoo-Kunde.
Die beiden haben sich im Waffelshop
kennengelernt und sofort verstanden.
Bens Körper
bietet einigen Platz für Mikes Kunst.
Tätowierungen
gehören zu Bens Geschäft.
Er ist Leadsänger
einer Heavy-Metal-Band.
Oh, it's freezing.
- Mike hat Glück:
Er konnte sich
auch im Shoppingcenter,
2 Min. entfernt vom Waffelshop,
einmieten.
Zu Spitzenzeiten,
wie das bis im August war,
bin ich 10 Std.
im WonderWaffel Store
und den Rest am Tätowieren.
Also oft hier.
Ich meine, ich habe
ein kleines Tattoo-Studio eröffnet.
Nur ich, keine anderen Künstler.
Ich pierce nicht.
Und ich werde so überrannt.
Das ...
... übertrifft
alle meine Erwartungen.
Ich mache das gerne.
Ich lebe dafür.
Es ist relaxing für mich.
Daher ...
... nehmen wir das so an.
It goes fast.
I'm almost done with the lines.
That's the fun part.
- Yeah.
* Entspannte Musik *
In Italien
ist die Unterschrift gesetzt,
der Kaufvertrag gültig.
Ist das gut?
... oder Morgen.
Das ist kein Problem.
(Mann) Vielen Dank,
dass du das so gepflegt übergibst.
Es sah ganz anders aus.
Vielen Dank.
Wir haben das Projekt gekauft ...
(Eva) Es wird noch gepflegter sein.
Wir werden noch alles saugen
und die Fliegen wegputzen.
Ich bin eine Schweizerin.
Das geht nicht anders.
Ruckzuck
und die Deutschen müssen weiter.
Gehen wir weiter?
Diesen feierlichen Akt
beschliessen wir
mit der Schlüsselübergabe
des Poderes Anfora della Vita.
(Mann) Ich bedanke mich.
- Okay.
Tschau.
- Tschau.
Und mit diesem Akt beendet Eva
ein weiteres Kapitel ihres Lebens.
Tschau.
- Tschau.
Dass sie ein Agriturismo in der
Toskana besass, ist somit Geschichte.
Eine wechselvolle Geschichte.
Eine Geschichte, in der sich Traum
und Realität nicht finden konnten.
Das habe ich eigentlich nie,
dass ich zurückschaue und denke:
"Hätte ich doch nicht."
Das denke ich nie.
Ich denke: "Ich habe."
"Ich habe daraus gelernt
und viele Erfahrungen gemacht."
Und ich sah für mich,
dass das nicht meine Gegend ist.
Das ist eine megagute Erkenntnis.
Und daher bin ich nicht ...
... wütend, dass ich
diese Erfahrung gemacht habe.
Ich bin dankbar,
dass ich sie machen durfte.
Ich habe auch
mit meinen Kindern besprochen,
nicht mehr weiter als 6 Std.
von der Schweiz entfernt zu sein.
Ich werde ja nicht jünger.
Bestimmt, Eva wird nicht jünger.
Ihre Abenteuerlust
jedoch scheint ungebrochen.
In Frankreich ist Gian
einem Fussballklub beigetreten:
dem ASR Machecoul.
Der Mannschaftssport hilft,
in der neuen Heimat Fuss zu fassen.
Doch, er macht das gerne.
Er hat hier auch seine Schulfreunde.
Der eine hat gerade was am Fuss
und sollte nicht spielen.
Mit ihm und mit einem anderen
geht er zur Schule.
Und hier hat er auch neue Freunde.
Die Kinder hier
sind ziemlich unkompliziert.
Sie haben ihn
extrem gut aufgenommen.
Auch sprachlich anfangs.
Sie halfen ihm extrem
mit Gesten usw.
Sie halfen ihm
mit Händen und Füssen.
Mittlerweile
ist das gar kein Problem mehr.
Wenn man ein Kind hat,
integriert man sich mehr.
Das ergibt sich dann so.
Ohne Gian wären Sandro und ich
mehr auf die Farm ...
... auf den Hof konzentriert.
Dadurch ist ...
... man etwas offener.
Man hat mehr Anlässe
und spricht dann auch mit Leuten.
Man nahm uns auch gut auf.
Sie sind neugierig, die Franzosen.
Das merkt man.
Sie wollen wissen, warum wir
gerade hierhergekommen sind
und warum wir nicht in der
reichen Schweiz geblieben seien.
"Ihr habt doch alles." Ja.
Keine Freizeit hat heute der Vater.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Der unermüdliche Macher
ist einmal mehr ...
... am Optimieren.
Du weisst, wie es ist:
Schlussendlich
macht der Chef den grössten Scheiss.
Wenn du nicht bereit bist,
das zu machen, bist du kein Chef.
Den Krieg
gewinnt man nicht auf dem Sofa.
Wiesers schaffen sich
einen neuen Mistschieber an.
So ...
Der alte hat seine Tücken
und bleibt immer wieder hängen.
Bei 8'000 m3 Jauche im Jahr
muss der funktionieren.
Es sind
wieder mal die Superingenieure,
die solche Sachen konstruieren.
Das läuft ja dann
permanent in den Kühen drin.
Das ist programmiert.
Und überall hat es scharfe Kanten.
Ich verstehe das nicht.
Die Kühe
sind Familie Wiesers Lebensgrundlage.
Ihnen darf nichts zustossen.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Der ging rein. Gesetzt.
Cool.
Super gemacht.
Wir sind nicht die Besten,
aber auch nicht die Schlechtesten.
Ja.
Hoi. Fini?
Müsst ihr noch was hinübernehmen?
Alles gut? Müde?
- Ja.
Pierre!
Gian ist nicht nur
auf dem Hof Les Aubiers angekommen,
er hat in Frankreich
auch Freunde gefunden.
* Entspannte Musik *
* Lockere Musik *
Trotz der Freude am Waffelshop,
etwas hat Marina
spätestens in den USA gelernt:
Veränderungen können
unangekündigt und plötzlich kommen.
Thank you.
- You're welcome.
Ein weiteres
amerikanisches Standbein wäre gut.
You're welcome. Thank you.
Und Marina hat auch schon
eine neue Geschäftsidee.
Ich mache es immer noch sehr gerne.
Ich bin gerne hier,
v.a. wenn viel läuft.
Gleichzeitig habe ich gemerkt,
dass ich etwas brauche ...
Etwas,
bei dem ich selbstständig bin,
aber nicht ortsgebunden.
Mein grösster Traum:
So zu arbeiten, dass es
keine Rolle spielt, wo ich bin.
Darum bin ich interessiert an VA,
an virtueller Assistentin.
Über eine eigene Homepage
möchte sie Firmen kaufmännische
Dienstleistungen und Inhalte
für deren soziale Medien anbieten.
Aufgaben, die sie
während der letzten zwei Jahre
täglich für den Waffelshop macht.
Weitere Angestellte
wie ihre Storemanagerin Maddie
sollen das bald möglich machen.
Schon am frühen Nachmittag Schluss
machen, das liegt schon heute drin.
* Lachen *
Bye. Have fun.
- Tschüss.
Bye-bye.
* Entspannte Musik *
An der Tarpon Springs High School
ist jeweils um 14 Uhr Schulschluss.
Austauschstudentin Alina
kommt mit dem Bus nach Hause.
Obwohl hier bei Papa
alles cool und easy ist:
Schnell hat sich die 15-Jährige
in den USA nicht eingelebt.
Am Anfang
war mein Heimweh sehr schlimm.
Ich musste jeden Tag weinen
und habe alles vermisst.
Aber mit der Unterstützung
von Papi wurde es besser.
Aber es gibt immer noch
solche Zeiten, das ist normal.
Ich bin auf einem anderen Kontinent.
Ja.
Hallo?
- Hoi.
Hallo.
Können wir die Schuhe ...
Wir haben langsam
etwas viel Schuhe hier.- Egal.
Ihr Englisch
muss Alina noch verbessern, bestimmt.
Bereits gelernt aber hat sie: Es
lohnt sich, nicht sofort aufzugeben.
Vielleicht
hat sie das beim Vater abgeschaut.
Heute geht es in den Norden
der Stadt, nach Port Richey.
Hier gibt es die legendären Tikibars.
Der Besuch einer solchen Bar
ist ein Must.
Ein weiteres Must
ist der Mückenspray.
Ohne Spray
geht man in Florida nicht ans Wasser.
Es hat mich in die Stirn gestochen.
- Hast du dich auch eingesprayt?
Auf der Stirn ...
- Nein.
Aber wenn sie hier kommen, kommen
sie auch hier überall.- Egal.
Egal. Uh!
Die Verbundenheit mit der Familie
war für Marina schon immer wichtig.
In den USA hat sich dieses Gefühl
noch verstärkt.
Wir kommen sehr gut miteinander aus.
Ich kann mit Alina
über Dinge sprechen ...
... über die sie mit anderen
nicht sprechen kann.
Ich bin eine Aussenstehende
und gehöre trotzdem zur Familie.
Ich helfe ihr, wo ich nur kann.
Sie ist wie meine eigene Tochter.
Sie ist mir ans Herz gewachsen. Ja.
Wir freuten uns extrem.
Wir hatten vorher schon
viel Kontakt,
als wir in der Schweiz waren.
Ich habe das letzte Jahr
sehr darauf gehofft,
dass die Schulzeit fertig ist
und sie kommt.
Er ist noch immer der gleiche Alte.
- Danke.
Etwas älter, aber ja ...
Nicht mehr der gleiche Alte,
sondern der Ältere.
Der ältere Alte.
Der Waffelshop war das Ticket
zu ihrem amerikanischen Traum.
Heute hat Mike
zudem ein Tattoo-Studio.
Und auch Marina will bald
neue Pläne in Angriff nehmen.
Es scheint, die Schweizer
haben ihren amerikanischen Traum
noch lange nicht ausgeträumt.
* Entspannte Musik *
Vielleicht
wird Gian Farmer in Kanada.
Das Rüstzeug dazu
bekommt er in Frankreich.
Sein Papa lässt ihn heute zum
ersten Mal den Futtermischer lenken.
Die grösste Maschine auf dem Hof.
11 t schwer ist sie.
Langsam hinfahren, den Kopf ...
Den Dings heben ...
Nach hinten ziehen.
Noch mehr.
Bis nach oben. Bis du drüber bist.
Es kann nichts passieren.
Nach vorne fahren. Langsam.
Gut.
Früh übt sich.
Nein, der Papa sitzt drin,
das ist immer gut.
Er macht das super.
Er hat grosses Interesse
an den Maschinen.
Mehr an den Maschinen
als an den Tieren. Aber egal.
Rückwärtsfahren. Da ist die Kamera.
Überall hat es Kameras
und dort den Spiegel.
Das Auftanken der Maschine
ist Teil der heutigen Aufgabe.
Wichtig ist, sie leger und locker
heranzuführen - wenn sie wollen.
Wenn ich gedrängt hätte, "Du musst
jetzt mit mir Futter mischen",
wäre das etwas anders.
Er will.
Er soll selber die Motivation haben.
Dafür, was ihm Freude macht.
Er hat ein Flair für Maschinen,
das weiss ich.
Mir ist es manchmal wohler,
dass er auf dem Teleskop sitzt
anstatt ein Mitarbeiter.
Alles will gelernt sein.
Auch das akribische Führen
des Tankbüchleins.
Ja, Gian ist motiviert.
Doch was immer
er künftig machen wird -
an Selbstvertrauen
soll es ihm nicht mangeln.
Denn wenn nur schon die Eltern
an einen glauben, ist alles möglich.
* Verträumte Musik *
Auch die Auswanderung seiner Eltern
ist geglückt
und ist damit ein gutes Beispiel,
dass sich Träume erfüllen können.
Ihren Auswanderungstraum
in die Tat umsetzen
wollen auch Anita Thomi
und Alain Aegerter.
Mit über 60 Schildkröten
und Schlangen
wandern sie nach Griechenland aus.
Ihre Idee:
Ferien für Reptilienfreunde anbieten.
Das ist das Zeichen,
dass man wirklich hierbleibt:
Wenn man das eigene Bett aufstellt.
Aber das Schicksal
hat einen anderen Plan:
Ein verheerender Waldbrand legt
ihr neues Daheim in Schutt und Asche.
Es tut mir um alles leid.
Das sind Millionen von Dingen.
Ist der Auswandertraum von Anita
und Alain damit gescheitert?
Eigenständigkeit
und mehr Zeit miteinander,
das sucht Familie Rotzler.
In Schweden
soll der Wunsch Wirklichkeit werden.
Sie kaufen
eine Ferienanlage mitten im Wald.
Bis vor einigen Tagen
hatten wir ein anderes Zuhause
an einem ganz anderen Ort.
Es ist aber megaschön.
Das ist megaschön.
Gratis dazu: viel Gerümpel.
Oh ja.
Die nächsten zwei bis drei Jahre
werden wir damit beschäftigt sein,
mal wirklich auszumisten,
aufzuräumen ...
Die Anlage auf Vordermann bringen
wird zur Herkulesaufgabe.
Nicht aufs Bett, das ist
schön gemacht für die Gäste.
Gerade halten.
Schau, dass du es gerade hältst.
Bleibt da noch Zeit
für mehr Familienleben?
Smaklig maltid.
Und auf und davon nach Kanada.
(Frau) So schön, so schön.
Auf Prince Edward Island glauben
Barbara Hasenböhler und Thomas Range
noch etwas bewegen zu können.
Ihr riesiges Anwesen wollen sie in
ein exklusives Gästehaus verwandeln.
Du hast hier das eine Zimmer
und dann hier ist es komplett offen,
mit der ganzen Meeresfront.
Doch alles verzögert sich.
Wenn wir im Juli/August
nicht offen sind ...
... haben wir
ein finanzielles Problem. Ganz klar.
Als der Umbau endlich läuft,
bricht sich Barbara einen Knöchel
und fällt aus.
Ja, Schatz,
ich rutsche aus dem Rollstuhl.
Werden sie
trotzdem rechtzeitig eröffnen können?
Bin ich happy in der Situation?
Nein.
Die neue Staffel
ab 6. Januar auf SRF 1.
# U si löi hie alles zrugg ...
# ... uf dr Suechi fürnes nöis Dehei.
# Si gö hüt no uf u drvo.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023